aún no le podemos dar el adiós
definitivo a las mascarillas en españa'
pero poco a poco su uso queda reservado
para ciertos momentos hoy mismo dejó de
ser obligatoria en exteriores pero habrá
que seguir llevándola en interiores
abiertos al público y en eventos
multitudinarios esta decisión llega
después de que en diciembre se volviera
a imponer su obligatoriedad al aire
libre ante el avance de la variante
omicron que hizo que los casos se
dispararan hasta cifras nunca vistas en
toda la pandemia en el país según el
gobierno español la medida se puede
tomar gracias al éxito de la vacunación
en españa donde más del 90 por ciento de
los mayores de 12 años tiene la pauta
completa aún así se pide prudencia y es
que españa sigue superando los 60 mil
contagios diarios y este miércoles se
registraron
282 fallecidos con lo que el país superó
así las 95 mil muertes por kobe 19 hay
opiniones mixtas en la calle algunos las
seguirán llevando mientras el número de
casos siga alto y otros respiran más
tranquilos sabiendo que pueden salir con
la cara al descubierto también aumenta
el aforo en eventos deportivos del 75 al
80 en exteriores y del 50 al 75 en
lugares cerrados eso sí quienes vayan a
los estadios tendrán que llevar puesto
el tapabocas